so welcome I'm Joe Carey ganas I'm at
the American assembly at Columbia this
is Dennis tenon in the English
departments we've been a couple of the
principles on the project and it's what
we hope is early days this is a very
exciting moment for us one in which all
the conversations we've been having over
the last year or so in some cases longer
with many of you can finally come to the
come together with the infrastructure
we've been building to try and support
those conversations so it's been our
goal to create a kind of Superfriends of
people who had an interest in what you
can do with syllabi and that goes back a
long ways we're hardly the first people
to think about syllabi as rich
unexploited resources that can tell us a
lot not just about teaching but about
the evolution of fields about
administrative practices about they can
lead in the direction of new kinds of
publication metrics the ancestor project
from our perspective I think has always
been Dan Cohen's million syllabus
project and we have to some extent
picked up that work and remind all of
those links and all of the syllabi that
and thought he had back in the day are
now to the extent that they're findable
we found them and have integrated them
into that base so I'll say a bit about
the agenda but first since I don't know
that we have any other explicit moment
to talk about it I belong to make sure
that everybody knew what the project is
and potentially where they can fit it
where they can connect with it so this
is you know a very simplified map of
what I think of as not really you know
components but the different levels at
which that levels at which the work is
being conducted so at the top it's
really a question about how you collect
syllabi where they come from what kinds
of social and legal arrangements you
need in order to get a hold of them once
and then get a hold of them again in the
future as we try and build a resource
that consultants self-sustaining and
the database you'll hear more about it's
a document database the API you'll hear
more about we finally have and can
expose and give out so that people can
begin to think about what kinds of tools
they can build with the data that the
API exposes beginning with the full text
of the syllabi but those are the
applications are really where I think
our diverse range of agendas can be
supported on what we hope will be a
common platform I my interest in syllabi
going back I've had a lot to do with
alternative publication metrics with
beginning to develop empirical accounts
of what fields are as opposed to what
people think they are what they argue
about or what they think they should be
on the assumption that a field is first
and foremost the knowledge that it
chooses to reproduce and syllabi are the
best guide to that institutional
comparisons become possible in ways that
are just impossible now curricular
discovery for students for faculty for
administrators although there are lots
of things lots of directions in which
this could go and now it's really the
time when we can begin to test some of
those propositions and to see how many
of your agendas can be facilitated by
some of the infrastructure work we've
been doing and then on the user side
again it's kind of an open field obvious
teaching applications research
applications around the curricular
history cannon cannon formation field
formation student discovery of course
materials especially as they soar
unified Silla semester long course
begins to be broken up in different ways
administrative tools for things like
discovery of adjacent seasoned teaching
so if you're wondering who's teaching
courses them did I come out of a decade
of conversations about what
Communications and Media Studies is and
every field has produced its own version
of its own answer to that and they all
overlap so if you're asking this who's
teaching work on an Internet policy in a
given semester there may be all sorts of
parallel activity that is the fact that
note the fact that the faculty is
ill-equipped
to understand or even identify so there
are lots of things like that that we
think we think the this open syllabus
project can support and now is really
the you know we will have a lot of
conversations about the these different
levels and the challenges that are
present at each of them but we're also
hoping to kind of to use the day and
tomorrow to forge a community that can
begin to work together more closely than
we've been able to do in the last year
so those are the primary goals of the
project day one is mostly just about
those different levels and their
respective challenges you know the
really we hope that this will be a
primarily discussion focused day so
everybody that is slated to present
should really think of their
presentations as brief introductions to
the way they have encountered some
version of these issues and as in
cetaceans to conversations so we want
this to be very back and forth and you
know there's it's not presenters an
audience that really hopefully will
become a much more fluid conversation
Dennis and I will provide some light
moderation as needed if people are
running over time will brutally enforce
but you know conversation is really
designed to explore your needs and your
projects as well as ours and see where
the intersections are so that that's the
way we hope this until the hackathon
tomorrow is in a different place just
now that you've found this place you can
forget it
give them never begin to the butler
library which is a little bit more
easily found so it's the main library on
the Claude and there will be you know a
range of technical things going on
during the day but also a range of
non-technical ones related to some of
the policy issues around the project
communication documentation of the
project we we have a variety of things
that will benefit from
not just technical expertise but other
kinds of experience with and around
these these types of projects so please
come even if you don't anticipate
bringing a lot of coding skills to the
table so just nuts and bolts of the
project reimbursements keep receipts
mark linacre will be the contact person
for following up his email is in the
agenda and I'll ask him to follow up
proactively with each of you because
there's a fair amount of bureaucracy
attached to doing anything at Columbia
including getting reimbursed for meals
and taxis and whatnot so that's a
somewhat over complicated but necessary
part of the process and Mark will be the
main contact person I do you want to
introduce Carla Garcia she's here Carla
just ok Carla is the other person you
may be talking to as far as
organizational backend of the conference
and Sarah monks is the haman staff
coordinator in case there are other
payment elated things today and Karla
Garcia from the American assembly
Christine Lu who's been the coordinator
for the project over the last year
and has done terrific work and pick
jurors and recording we are filming the
event it's not not live-streaming but it
is designed to be a record in case the
project falls apart tomorrow there will
be some record of how we got to at least
this far so that the next you know OSP
two and ten years can pick up where we
left off competing standards okay so it
did occur to me we should have a scratch
pad maybe a Google Doc or something so
that people want to share links
resources other kinds of comments that
leave it open and send the link around
maybe any other logistical issues that
we should be aware of at the stage okay
well with that I will
and then the first session is really
edited do you want to say a bit at the
technical level is that an adequate
thank you I think I'm gonna just speak
at the next session okay say my piece
thing well with that we have a session
it's sort of a opening discussion of the
different reasons people are interested
in these and these doctors documents and
the the kinds of projects that have been
underway in some cases longer than hours
to try and pull it together and and make
syllabi useful for some of the purposes
we've been discussing